んだと そこでそれを覚えておかないと困るんです
この八つを 八つまとめたところでユニット一つなんです
それでだいたい物質の話はそこで終わります
が もうちょっと残ってるんですね
どうやって生まれるかと
どうしようかな これ時間かかるんです
じゃあまあもう 4時半ですからね
そこで 4時までですか
一応あの言葉だけでいきましょう
これからは 次にこの 186 ページにこのルートサムティヤ・ニダネ
どういう風に物質が生まれますかと
物質の生まれ 生まれる方法
起こり方を説明するんですね
物質はだいたいカンマ
チッタ ウトゥ アハアラという 4つの原因で生まれる
それは業 心 受想 識かな
触という 4つの原因で生まれるんだと
いわゆる識が生まれる原因は 4つあるんです
1番目は業 カンマ その心のこと説明してないんだから
一応ここら辺に詳しく知る必要はないんです
あのカルマっていうのは業であって
この我々はこの意識していろんなことをするんですね
何かやるとやったことによって
このポテンシャルとして何か残っちゃうんです
どうせ何かしたら それにはもう次の結果が現れるでしょ
それもやむを得ないものなんですね
いつでも一つの行為が次の行為を生み出すんです
で ここに暖房つけたならば
結果として空気が暖かくなるんです
暖房をつけたんだから
ずっと冷えたんですよとは言えないんですね
そこで暖房をつけてならば
それは電気で動くものだったら
当然電気は消費しちゃうんです
そういう風にこの物の流れというか
ありますね それはアクションリアクションと
リアクションなんですか？で
そういう風な作用と反作用という風に
このチェーンリアクションで行うものなんですね
ですから 心が生まれたらそれなりの結果が次に出てくるんです
それはもうやむを得ないものなんです
そういうのはもうカルマみたいなカルマの働きなんです
例えば ものすごく自分が腹が立って怒ってしまった
それすっごく怒ってしまったならば
それなりの結果は必ず次から次へ生まれるんです
止められることできない
怒って何かしたわけじゃない
ただ心の中で怒っただけなんです
心の中で怒っただけでも
次から次へそちらの結果が反作用が生まれてくるのです
そこで怒ったところで
怒った結果として悪口を言うと
人の悪口を言うと 人のことを怒りましたと
人のことを怒りましたんだから
そちらの反作用として悪口を言うでしょ
悪口言ったことの反作用として
また違う結果が生まれてくる
極仏教の世界では 私が怒ったっても人に悪口言いませんと
内心で怒っただけですよと
だから自分がもう大丈夫だ
大丈夫だと 大丈夫ではないんです
内面的に怒っても内面的に怒ったならば
その分は結果がある 内面的に怒った結果として言葉を喋ったならば
それなりの結果がまた次から出てくる
他の行動したならばそれなりの結果が出てくる
それはもう止まってもらうことはもうありえない話
無理な話 それはカルマというんです
よく普通なこの行為のチェーンリアクション
限りなく繋げる 終わりがない
そこでなんでカルマと言うんですかというと
例えば物質は物質のチェーンリアクションを持ってるんですね
それは別にどうってことない
この心のチェーンリアクションなんですね
まあ例えばこの水が川にあって
それでダムを作ったりして
そこで水がそこでポテンシャルは持ってるようになって
それからこのタービンを回したりして
そこから電気は生まれてきて
その電気でそんなつなげてきて
その そういう風な この物質のチェーンリアクションになるんですね
それでその水がどんどんポテンシャルが消えちゃって
海に海に行ってしまって
それで海からまた熱で上にあがって
太陽の上にあがったりして
また雨としてまた川に戻ったりとか
まあそういう風にも限りなくもう回っている
そこで我々は電気を使っていてとか
そこに心はないんだから
まあ別に放っておけばいいんです
同じ循環ですか 心の中にもあるんです
私は人を見ると心で見ているんだから
心の中で反応を起こす
その反応によって次の心が生まれる
その心によって人を見
人を見たり 考えたり 喋ったりすると
それによってまた次の心が生まれてくると
その流れがもうどうしようもない流れなんです
ですから 心の中の起こるこのチェーンリアクションみたいなものはカルマになっちゃうんです
だから 怒りやら悪い心が生まれたら悪いリアクション
悪いチェーンになっちゃうし
いい心が生まれたらいいチェーンになってしまっちゃうし
例えば自分がみるみる人を大変褒めてあげるんだと
いわゆるおだてることではなくて
本当にその人々持っているいいところだけ見て褒めてあげると
ですから その人は人のいいところしか見ない
丁寧に人を褒めているんだから
おだてるものは悪いことだからね
そこで人のいいことしか見ないんだから
その人は明るい心を持たなくちゃいけないんですね
悪いとこ見たっても まあそんなことがあったってても
本当はその人はこういう点でいい人だよと
すぐそういうふうに見てしまっちゃうでしょ
それで人のいいところしか見ない人だから
他の人々を その人には自分持っているいいところしか見せないんです
例えば人がいて ものすごく人を騙すんだと
人を騙すんだけど 優しい心を持ってるんだと
完全な悪人じゃはないんだと
そこで人を騙すし まあ優しい心を持ってる人がいて
またもう一人の人は人のいいところしか見ない人をよく褒めてるんだ
その人とこの人を合わせたら
この人を騙す人はこの人を騙そうとはしないんです
その代わりにその人の優しい側面だけ見せちゃう
そういうふうな そこでバンバンザイでしょ
問題ないんだから こういう風になっちゃうんですね
ですから 自分持っている心
心によって周りの心の態度も変わってしまっちゃいます
例えば噂ばっかし言いたくて
いる人々いるんですね
噂っていうのは人の悪いとこ
その人がいないところで言うことなの
定義としては ですから
噂よく言いたがる人々はいつでも世の中見て
何が欠点ないか 何かあの人のそればっかし見てるんですね
汚い醜いところ あの人浮気しているんではないか
他の人は会社でごまかしながらやってるんではないかとかね
だからすっごい醜い 醜いと言っても
そういうふうに欠点だけ見てるんですね
欠点だけ見てるんだから
残念ながらその人に人の欠点しか見えなくなっちゃう
そこであの人が 人を騙す人が
人を騙す言うんだけど
その人を人に優しいところ持ってるでしょ
この噂の人はあなたよく人を騙しますねと言っちゃうでしょ
そうすると その人の優しい分でこの人に反応は出てこないんですね
だから同じAさんに会った C
さん Dさんがいて Cさんは人のいいとこしか見ない D
さんは人の悪いとこしか見ない C
さんは人を褒めていく
Dさんは人の噂を流す
そうすると Cさんには見たAさんが大変優しい人で証拠もあるんです D
さんにはAさんは大変人を騙す悪い人で証拠もあるんです
そこでCさんDさんがお互いに喧嘩する
喧嘩にはなりませんだけど
論文書いたところで A
さんはこういう証拠を持ちまして悪い人やと A
さんがこういう証拠から見るといい人やと言えるんだけど
どっちでも自分の心次第ですね
とにかく心によって この心の持ち方によって
このチェーンが チェーン作用が変わるんです
そこはカルマなんですね
それが 大変申し訳ないんだけども
日本で言ってるような簡単単純でないんですけどね
カルマ論は そこでカルマで
カルマから物質が生まれるということは
こういうカルマをすると同時に体の中で変化が起こる
そういうことで 明るくなってくると
いいことをすると どんどん気持ちよくなってきて
あの脳内革命なんとかって本で言ってるような考えであってもいいし
いいことをするとすごい気持ちがいいし
気持ちがいいということは
脳がいいホルモンを出してくれるし
そうすると 例えばね いい
あの 何て言いますか その脳内のいい物質を出してくれると
大変細胞は喜んで 自分も喜んで
そこで当然病気も治るわ
健康にもなるわ 何のことなく幸福になってしまっちゃうんですね
ですから この医学的に脳内革命という本で書いてますから
このエンドルフィンですか
そういういいエンドルフィン出してくれると
それはやっぱり喜ばなきゃ生まれてこないんですね
いいことをしたら簡単に喜べるんです
ただのクリスマスパーティーやったんだ
忘年会やったんだからといって
もう喜ぶところじゃなくて
後ですごい後悔するものばっかりなんですね
みんなよくやりますけど
ものすごい大騒ぎにパーティーとかね
後で大変なんですよ ですからその瞬間だけと
でもいいことをすればそうじゃなくて
本当に喜んで良くなってきます
それは証拠あるものだから
だから仏教では まあカルマでは仏教にそういう人はどんないいんです
人は悪いことをしようがいいことじゃそんなこと関係ないんだけど
このチェーンリアクションから見れば
いいことをすると いい物質はいい組み合わせで生まれる
悪いことをすると悪い組み合わせで生まれてくる
人が苦労したってでも幸福になったって
不幸になったって それは別に気にしない
別にそこら辺どうでもいいんですが
まあ本人個人的には不幸になりたくないと思うならばいいことをしなさいと
それだけのことで 別に仏教は大きなお世話でいろいろお説教をしているわけじゃないんです
みんなそこを誤解しているんです
仏教はあれやめなさい
これやめなさいとものすごくうるさいんだと
全然それじゃないんです
どうぞご自由にやってくださいと
それだけのことで 自分が幸福になりたければ
こういうことをしてくださいと
こういうことをやめなさいと
それは自分の意志で それカルマから生まれる物質はいっぱいではなく
小さいカーブだけなんです
カルマから小さいカーブ
ですから いい心作ってみてください
どんどんどんどん体がよくなっちゃいます
で どんな心でどんな物質が生まれるかっていうことはあります
もう時間です  で